we are all writers now whether you want
to write a
book or a blog or better text messages
or emails
i want to help you with a free ebook
called 11 ways to write better you can
find that
at the minimalists.com resources
enjoy minimalists
my daughter is somewhat of a hoarder
what are some of the scientific theories
regarding hoarding how can i get her to
see that she doesn't need all that stuff
she sees everything as a sentimental
treasure
our things have sentimental value only
because we have imparted
sentimentality onto them right yeah and
there's a reason that ryan if you have a
so i have a hat box of my mother's right
it's the
i think it's the one sentimental item i
still have of hers besides photographs
which are being stored digitally now
right and so i have this hat box of hers
and that is a sentimental item to me but
sentimentality is highly perspectival
yeah so much so that that box is not
sentimental to anyone else
unless i were to give it to a hoarder
then it might be sentimental to them
because it's easy for a hoarder to
impart
sentiment onto anything our things have
no meaning
other than the meaning we give to them
there's no inherent
meaning no intrinsic meaning to any
object so back to what axel vevort was
saying
i'm not the collector who wants to
possess i want to give things a better
place
however if we use that sort of
thinking to justify our things
you end up being the opposite of axel
vivort
axel is even though he's a maximalist in
some
ext to some extent the objects he has
are beautiful
it looks like a museum in his house a
slightly cluttered museum but a museum
nonetheless yeah and i found that these
hordes actually take away i went out to
um
the ames house the case study house i
think it's number eight or number nine
yeah and uh charles and ray ames both
lived there was their main residence for
a long time and they've sort of restored
it and kept it how it was
in its heyday but they kept it how it
was
after his heyday as well when rey after
charles died ray she lived there for
an extended period and she started
collecting a bunch of objects
and they were beautiful objects but
here's the thing about beautiful objects
when you just
place them all into a a pile yeah it's
like a magic field of landfill ryan
with beautiful objects right it's
still a trash heap yeah it's still a
landfill
right right and some of the trash might
be less dirty than other pieces of trash
i heard someone talk about this recently
but like i think it was kapil gupta
and uh he was talking about thoughts
though like
someone asked him like well don't you
ever have negative thoughts he's like
well
negative positive doesn't matter all
thoughts are garbage
so you go to a landfill there's some
garbage that's cleaner than other
garbage doesn't mean it's not garbage
i would say the same thing about our
hordes and we have these beautiful
objects we've collected all of them
amassed them all of a sudden
the meaning that we once imparted on a
few things
we now give to this whole horde and it
renders it meaningless in a way
now unfortunately the second part of
your question
how can i get her to see that she
doesn't need all that stuff
yeah you can't yeah and that's
you know we've been doing this for going
it's over 10 years
at this point yeah and we still haven't
found that answer how do you convince
someone else that they need to be a
minimalist
yes i mean it's because it's not about
convincing
it's about offering help when one asks
for help
and it's about showing them the benefits
in your own life but you can't
there's nothing that you can tell your
daughter to get her to see that she
doesn't need all that stuff
the one thing i don't know you know i
don't know if if
her if simply joyfully here is
contributing to the sentimental stuff
but
stop buying her presents if you are
right now i mean that's one way that you
might be able to help
is to say physical gifts you can give
different gifts
yeah that's yes exactly thank you so
buying her something that she might see
is sentimental
um and she's probably already doing that
but but yeah other than that
like you can't do anything beyond
your own actions simply joyfully yeah
and maybe the other thing anthony demelo
would say you can't help people see the
truth you can help them see what isn't
the truth
um interesting you can't show someone
reality
but you could show them what isn't
reality and you know what isn't reality
here
sentiment yeah that's not real it's not
tangible you've assigned
sentiment it doesn't make it any less
real for your daughter
but when you can show her that it's not
reality you may not be able to show her
what the reality is
but you can show her what isn't reality
yeah the question too might be
like what is the deeper truth here like
why does she look at everything
as a sentimental treasure so what else
is going on
in her life that makes her feel that way
and there might be
something you can you know bring up to
your daughter that might help her
gain a different perspective i mean if
anything like that's
maybe that's the one thing and i'm just
like talking this out loud so i don't
know if this is
really accurate or not but that is the
one thing maybe you can do with
others you can't force them into doing
things but maybe you can create a
conversation
that offers a different perspective yeah
and and
but before you even do that because i
think the language often taints things
yes ryan when you came to me and said
and discovered minimalism it wasn't
about
the the language around it right
it was about the feeling around it the
essence of it
right and so yes you can get to the
essence but you can almost
you can almost never get to the essence
with language i think about uh
think about it this way if you get onto
montana one of the most beautiful places
you could be
right absolutely you get on a
greyhound bus there and they dr draw all
the shades right yeah and even if you
have a poet at the wheel
on the intercom describing what's going
on outside the window
um it's not going to even come close
yeah to the the essence the truth
it may have a bunch of facts you could
put david foster wallace nessie who
writes about nature better than
anyone in a way that like
you almost feel as though you're there
but it's looking
at a rainbow and grayscale it's not the
same
thing so you can't explain what is real
but you could say what isn't out that
window and that might help
that might help them understand and as
you said it may
that may make way for the conversation
so you can talk about some of your own
experiences that you've gone through